president-elect Donald said in his
post-election 60 minutes interview that
his plan is to deport 2 to 3 million
undocumented immigrants when he is sworn
into office and this has been a big
reason why Donald Trump appealed to a
pretty significant portion of his base
right his immigration related rhetoric
his promises of deportation forces his
discussions about a wall with Mexico
this has all been a big reason of why
many of his supporters voted for him and
what's fascinating is that President
Obama has deported way more undocumented
immigrants than the number that Donald
Trump promises to deport so think about
that and think about if you follow the
narratives in media many many Trump
voters like Trump because as they see it
unlike Obama he's going to get going on
deportations which they're angry that
President Obama hasn't done so let's I
want to make sure you're armed with the
facts here according to a Pew Research
data analysis released in August the
Obama administration deported 2.4
million undocumented immigrants between
2009 when President Obama took office
and 2014 that's an unprecedented number
that's a record number of deportations
now that only gets us through 2014 if
you add just sort of like an average
number for 2015 and 2016 which is mostly
over at this point to that 2.4 million a
deportation number President Obama has
deported roughly 3.2 million
undocumented immigrants and that is more
again that is more than the number that
President Donald a president elect
Donald promises to deport now I want to
add to that not only has President Obama
deported more undocumented immigrants
than the number that president-elect
Donald says he will deport he didn't do
it with a wall that would be
outrageously expensive we actually have
a net outflow of immigrants to Mex
more people are moving back to Mexico
than coming to Mexico due to the United
States from Mexico rather and this is
not about pro Trump or anti Obama this
is about as an interesting Inquisitor
article that I recently read says
everybody needs to look at themselves if
you voted for Trump because you wanted
more people deported than what President
Obama has done well you're not going to
get that number of deportations because
Donald Trump's promise of the number of
people he will deport is a smaller
number than the number of people that
President Obama has already deported if
you are protesting the election of Trump
as a progressive because of his
immigration plans where were you while
Donald while President Obama rather
deported way more people than Trump
promises to this is really really really
why progressives need to understand how
to fight Trump and I've expressed my
practical concerns about some of the
protests but ideologically progressives
really need to figure out what is the
right way to fight Donald Trump and
protesting deportations that haven't yet
happened by Trump when most of you did
nothing to protest record deportations
under Obama is questionable and I would
argue may end up being counterproductive
during the administration of incoming
president Donald and that's exactly what
I want to talk about next in a very very
real way